susan b anthony oh there you go could
not believe it oh my god
it's a great segue into trump yes trump
did
it was a a major letdown you guys have
maybe saw this he announced last night
he was going to pardon someone very
important
i was so excited i'm like texting my
friends like it's it's not going to be
snow it's not going to be flynn is is
this is julian assange is he going to
party
is wikileaks my friends who are you know
big fans of wikileaks this is huge
i can't believe trump would pull this
off and then he announces it's
so posthumously pardoning susan b
anthony
by the time i was asking him about it i
was like who do you think it's going to
be is it going to be assange
he's like it's going to be someone that
i don't care about
yeah yeah oh okay i was like i'm i i'm
too familiar with politics
i was so excited so so anyway the point
is susan b anthony
was epic too she famously
defied the law to vote and got arrested
for it
and that's why we honor susan b anthony
with her face on a
on on a silver dollar on american you
know dollar coin
and trump did some boring presidential
you know typical nonsense i am gonna you
know today marks the 100th anniversary
of the 19th so we're pardoning susan
anthony
and that was it and yet the media
disparaged her then i i i shouldn't say
this
i said denigrate unfairly unfairly
criticized saying well she was racist
and she was you know opposed to abortion
and therefore
and now all these leftists are coming
out actually dragging susan b anthony
and i
i lost i started laughing when i saw
these stories
at first i was mad and then i was
laughing at first you were bad because
it wasn't
someone worthwhile like someone that's
alive that could enjoy the pardon now
and do good work you know rest in power
susan b anthony
but then he started laughing see this
the thing about him
is i don't get this they they
simultaneously call him a troll
but then they always take the bait so do
they not know what troll means
i guess not the media loves it
i think they want trump to win passively
because they're worried about their
ratings if he loses that's one of my
theories as well
as soon as they picked joe biden i was
thinking there's no way
they can put him in the debates they
just can't
not in the state he's in and and i say
that with sympathy for him because
watching him it makes me feel sad that
that there
that he's running and that no one has
told him oh man maybe take some time
but but anyway i was thinking wow maybe
they don't want to win
because they're picking him why would
they do that unless they want to wait
and get and build up because it's good
for them to have this anti-trump anger
and this
this fake resistance and they're not
resisting anything
the status quo they're the issues what
are you resisting you are the
establishment exactly
you're you're the cookie companies and
the soda companies and the major
broadcasters you're not
you are the resistance brought to you by
mcdonald's yes
yes seriously literally if if there is
some kind of weird conspiracy where the
democrats are purposefully trying to
lose and they're helping trump and
they're all in on it i just hope it
involves aliens you know
it's like it's gonna try to be something
dumb like some guy was like hey we make
good money off trump let's just
you know throw in the towel and get paid
or the democrats realize they can't win
so they set up some dummy candidates
doomed to fail
it's just boring politics but it'd be
really great if it was actually some
secret conspiracy
you know we all got to wear our masks
and clean our hands so that when the
aliens come we don't get them sick and
yeah
that would be fun there's going to be a
good build-up for something hey so
aliens apparently is not on the list of
things that youtube doesn't want us to
talk about
that's right they love it we're a lot of
talk about aliens
and we should okay good so one thing
that was really shocking me today
shocking to me today was trump
bought the most expensive ad space
on the internet the youtube banner and
it
it arguably is or is it but for the most
part most people say it is the most
expensive ad buy you could possibly make
trump did a seven-figure ad buy wow and
the new york times reported he was able
to do this
during the dnc because the democrats
didn't buy the ads
and what why
couple that with the embarrassing videos
you talked about the beginning
and again i don't know if they are
really running
i don't think they are can i uh can i
throw something in here yeah because i
pulled up the dnc
live stream pbs you know with two
million viewers you wanna know how many
viewers they have right now
they have eight thousand one hundred and
forty two viewers
well no it's just the one i know but
it's
it's ridiculous the actual dnc youtube
right now has 56 000 people watching
okay that's good that's great i'm proud
of them it's good for them yeah yeah
i'll tell you what we've got 46. yeah i
mean
wow where's a couple people hanging out
complaining about the democrats
yeah so it's way more fun we're
competing with the dnc we're competing
with all the other people making fun of
the dnc we're laughing a lot
in my opinion there are way more people
who have walked away left the left
and are mocking the democrats for their
unhinged
unprincipled sporadic
positions i mean like i don't even know
i don't i don't know what they're doing
i just want some authentic people to i
don't know what's going to happen if
trump wins i kind of think
so after 2016 they didn't learn the
lesson like i started trying to figure
out why he won because i wanted to make
sure he didn't win again
so i figured i should learn and
understand why he won
and and it red pilled you it totally i
guess red built me
but it also i lost a lot of friends who
basically said you know
it was racism and sexism period
and just the fact that you're sharing
these kinds of articles and sources and
things that you're looking into
it proves that you know basically your
your privilege allows you to blah blah
blah blah blah
um but they didn't learn the lesson and
so they've doubled down on social
justice
ideology and like you said maybe some of
it's just they're they're pandering to
whatever they think will help them win
and maybe they think it's the wokens and
we'll help them win
what happens next do they learn if they
lose again
the the you know there's a gallup poll
showing that up to 2018
the progressives have have basically
dominated the party
like about 46 in the past two years i'd
imagine it's even grown
further than that where there is a
downward trend within the democratic
party of moderates and conservatives and
an upward trend of
liberal so i think what they mean by
liberal is
they probably yeah they've taken over
and so you end up with
joe biden and kamala harris desperately
trying to pander to this younger
more progressive and further left on
multiple issues but
they still need the independence in the
internet in my opinion social media
censorship and bias has resulted in an
unhinged
you know chaotic destructive group of
people that don't understand what the
world is
i think that they're suffering from some
kind of
algorithmic derangement disorder so
what happens is i've talked about it
quite a bit these media companies
figured out how to maximize their reach
by mashing keywords together on facebook
if you interact with a certain kind of
content facebook feeds you more of it
they want you to stay on the site so
websites like buzzfeed and post
quickly started realizing what content
worked they put up a video about police
brutality
gets a million views they put up a video
about sexism
gets a million views racism another
million
what do you do you combine the three a
black woman was beaten by police racist
sexist police brutality and now they get
three million views
so what ends up happening is you have
all these mishmashed ideas that make no
sense
jammed together constantly being fed
through social media
the people who get rewarded on twitter
are the angriest meanest people who put
out the nastiest hot takes so it's
nothing but vitriol and hate and they
build a world view
based on unhinged paranoid delusions
you take a look at the post office
conspiracy theory going around right now
this is algorithmic derangement disorder
you know in play
people are being fed all of these
confirmation bias
nonsensical conspiracies and twitter
allows it
but they'll ban q on people you know you
you can't say learn to code on twitter
you'll get banned
but you can absolutely post a picture
from 2011 of a mailbox in a dumpster
and claim it's from today and you know
donald trump personally did it
and it goes viral it's amazing they
believe all of this stuff and their
world is just
garbled in nonsense like my friend i was
telling you about i see her post
she's like trump has deployed unmarked
secret police across this country
it never happened and i'm like this is i
remember
you know man 15 years ago or something
stumbling upon alex jones for the first
time and hearing him talking about
fema camps and all this other stuff and
now
alex jones is talking about donald trump
and for sure when he went on rogan he
talked about weird crazy stuff
but i'm i'm i'm saying they ban him
the left right now secret police
snatching people up never happened
you know trump deploying them across the
country stealing mailboxes a grand
conspiracy
none of it's happening and all of this
is unchecked russiagate
oh russiagate for sure yep
and now it's turning into an inverted
scandal of obamacare my fate one of my
favorite stories recently
rachel maddow was so obsessed with
russia
that she once claimed russia might turn
the electricity off in fargo
in the middle of winter when the durham
investigation actually gets an
indictment
someone's actually about to plead guilty
to altering
a document to essentially frame people
in trump administration
she didn't talk about it all no she
suddenly doesn't care because she
is the most prominent conspiracy
theorist right now in the country
hands down so what does she do she she
reads excerpts from michael cohen's book
you know hot takes salacious nonsense
about the president
she's just giving the people who are
already plugged into her and she's
giving them what they want
more of what they want it's like going
to your
you know people are going to get their
fix and she's giving them the drugs they
came for and that's it
absolutely i'm not going to give you
something different it might shock your
system
you know to be fair um i think my
content is fairly one-sided
obviously so you could criticize me in
very similar ways i ragged the democrats
all the time
you could do that to me too yeah i mean
i mostly our podcast is called unsafe
space we mostly
for the most part critique my old belief
system what i think is
a little different though is that the
network you know you're on youtube right
right yeah you want to shout out your
channel while we're here it's unsafe
space
on youtube for as long as we last here
yeah we're also on the other places
but so so think about the network we're
on you know
setting the algorithmic problems aside
youtube isn't nearly as bad as facebook
or twitter
you go on youtube and i see people in
the comments talking about jimmy dore
you know jimmy dore is i like to meet
her yeah exactly but is it
i don't want to you know point the
finger at him he's a socialist isn't he
is he
he's a progressive for sure and i don't
know if he calls himself socialist or
not but
yeah you i think that's pretty close to
what he believes on economic issues
but jimmy dore here's what i like about
jimmy dore he's a real progressive
right he's not a social justice warrior
definitely just like i'm i'm
dude i mean i don't care you're going to
call me right winger or some of you
anyway i don't care but i'm a liberal
i'm not a social justice word these
words mean something liberal means
something regressive means something
liberal's right wing no not crazy it
really is yeah
so but i know the point was when you're
on youtube
if you follow jimmy and you follow me
and you file uh you follow crowder
and you know uh say that was another
good example kalkalinsky
you're getting a mixed bag yeah you know
and i think there's one really
interesting thing about
the youtubers is we all kind of agree
with your left or right russiagate was
complete bs
yeah except jimmy dore absolutely
believe right for sure
you can turn on msnbc and if that's all
you watch
you're sitting in front of the idiot box
just eating up
you know refuse from the bottom of the
barrel you go on youtube
and the interesting thing about youtube
that all of these hit pieces missed they
tried claiming there's a rabbit hole and
stuff
is that if i make a video about
immigration and you watch it
and kyle kalinski or the young turks or
jimmy dore make a video about
immigration
youtube feeds you content based on the
subject matter
not the opinion on the subject matter so
you click hey i mentioned an immigration
boom
you might actually end up seeing a
progressives take on immigration
criticizing trump you turn on msnbc they
ignore
anything so you have no opportunity to
actually get
you know counter counterpoints and then
what ends up happening is what we're
seeing
the media across the board has pointed
to the left and just
darted so far the only thing we're
getting is hysteria
across the board they're bringing back
russiagate again i kid you not
yeah it's coming back baby they're
bringing russiagate back they're
screaming about the post office is not
true
secret police none of it's true it's
just all unhinged but if you're on
youtube
you get a mix of progressives moderates
conservatives
some of them are you know pushing fake
news for sure because we're not perfect
people
you know we get things wrong but it's
the opinions are across the spectrum but
they're not pushing fake news
under with the veneer of
uh expertise that the legacy media
has the legacy media pushes fake news
they push conspiracy theory
but they still have this veneer of
of you know authority right and as if
you're listening to something that's
unbiased and it disgusts me
and one of the things that bothers me
online is people we're living in a day
where
um a lot of people like to engage in
genetic fallacy you know so if you share
a link
to an opinion piece or a news piece or
something you like and they're if
they're on the right they'll say oh it's
it's vox i'm not going to read that and
if they're on the left they'll say
you know oh it's it's breitbart i'm not
going to read that
but but just read it i think if you're
an adult you should be able to read
anything and discern
opinion from the facts of the piece and
go find other sources and see what you
think about it
it's not going to hurt you if you're an
adult to read it right
but we're living in that place and one
of the differences i see though when
people play that game
is that the places on the left
they don't say what their bias is so if
you go to the about page of breitbart or
even like daily wire
they tell you on the about page
conservative leaning they'll tell you
but if you go to the about page of
buzzfeed it doesn't say
social justice leaning or leftist
leaning they just pretend
like they're a non-biased and not
disgust me and and
there's a there's a service i use called
newsguard actually you can see it it's
this little green checkmark that appears
in all these articles you can see the
new york times has a 100 credibility
rating from newsguard
newsguard will give the daily wire a
negative score
they get a red exclamation point because
you know they don't separate opinion
from fact and they have you know they've
published incorrect information before
it's an opinion website yes it's a
conservative opinion news aggregator
but media matters which is literally a
non-profit designed to smear the right
and publishes conspiracy fake news
nonsense non-stop it's a green check
mark
you're kidding so i use this i use this
service specifically for that reason
try and come at me and claim my sources
are bad when newsguard itself is
ridiculously biased
yeah ridiculously you know uh breitbart
had a green check mark for a while
meaning they're certified they're pretty
good
you know they're credible they did that
video of the doctors giving a press
conference
and now they're in review oh wow and i'm
like they're just a news organization
that interviewed someone
so when anderson not even even do an
interview they filmed a press conference
when anderson cooper has on the my
pillow guy and the my pillow guy is
talking about hydroxychloroquine in a
positive light
why don't they get put under review and
a review
because it's biased against the right
specifically any
you don't got to be left or right or
moderate it doesn't matter what you are
you can see it if you're being
reasonable and and trying to be
fair to the facts that the whole system
is rigged against people who are on the
right
but that requires being again to get
back to i guess philosophy or
or something it requires people being
vulnerable
and some people you know you have to
i'm trying to think of there's this guy
george lachoff he wrote this book don't
think of an elephant have you heard of
this
oh no but you made me think of an
elephant that's great
so it's a very quick read i read this
after bush one because
lockhoff he's a he's a linguist and he
was trying to explain to people on the
left why
people on the right so often disregard
facts
if it doesn't fit their narrative it's a
very good book what he missed was that
this happens on the left too it took me
a while to see that
yeah but but what he was trying to say
was that if you sort of think of your
ideology or your narrative the way you
look at the world as a house right
and then if you give somebody a fact
that doesn't fit their house
you're not just asking them to like
rebuild their window or their door frame
or something
sometimes it would require them to raise
their entire house of belief to the
ground
it's very hard for people to do it's
much easier to disregard that fact and
say oh you got it from breitbart goodbye
like and not look at it absolutely
it's hard you're asking people to i
don't yeah to be very
very emotionally vulnerable and to be
content with
losing friends and family and their
whole sin and their sense of identity
who they are
so many people wrap their identity up in
politics thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next episode
you